what's up everybody I'm Walter been AZ
AK and this is top five here we
countdown the best and worst
performances of our most beloved actors
today we take a look at the best of Bob
Barker's arch-nemesis Adam Sandler
before we get an Adam Sandler I wanted
to thank everybody for the big feedback
I've been getting on these past two
videos which were the top 10
performances of Robin Williams a lot of
people were reaching out to me on
Twitter and in the comments and
everything so if you've watched that
thank you very much and if you read it
reached out to me personally I really
appreciate it like I said before Robin
was a great performer one only guy so if
you haven't seen those videos yet
go back and check both of those out
right now and if you're gonna stay here
let's go ahead and get a damn Sandler Am
Sandler is still one of the biggest
movie stars in the world and after his
run on Saturday Night Live he struck a
big with fan favorites like Billy
Madison and happy gilmore later the
funny man took on more serious roles and
showed a lot of people just how talented
he really is comedy drama The Sandman
could do it all and these are as top
five best performances number five john
clasky in Spanglish Sandler plays a meek
husband and father in this 2004 romantic
dramedy he received a lot of praise for
his performance and stepping outside of
the wacky comedic roles he's known for
Flor is a Mexican immigrant and mother
who finds work housekeeping for the John
and Deborah klasky family in Los Angeles
when Fleur and her daughter move in with
the class keys for the summer the two
families often butt heads on how they're
raising their children the house is also
a high-tension environment because of
mrs. clasky eccentric behavior that
creates problems for everyone most
especially her husband John this is one
of the first big departures for Sandler
that drew a lot of attention to the fact
that he could do much more than just
crazy comedies it's a very understated
performance that Sandler played well
he's a father whose wife is very hard to
deal with and this causes him to
internalize some heavy emotions john is
a pretty easygoing guy who people walk
all over a little too much so when those
emotions are finally let loose it makes
for a strong scene yes you heard me it's
not like
you didn't do the same no yes you did so
why don't you go lecture yourself
whoa need a translator for that one what
am i lately a recycling bin
anybody dumping your garbage so if I
make something useful out of it
Sandler's character has a lot of heart
to him and when we see him hurt the pain
in his eyes is almost tangible real
short answer have you had yes really
this movie still has some great comedic
moments that Sandler is a big part of
but how he portrays his relationships
with his daughter and floor are the most
memorable aspects of Spanglish surviving
what how did you come up with this
fantastic funny I love you this is a
role that helped people see Adam in
another way it progressed his career and
contributed to his staying power number
for Sonny Koufax in Big Daddy by 1999
Sandler had established himself as a
leading comic actor big daddy was
another classic comedy of his that
showed early signs of his dramatic range
Sonny Koufax is a lazy thirty
two-year-old who only works once a week
while collecting money from a sizeable
lawsuit when a young boy named Julian is
dropped on his doorstep with a note that
claims his roommate is the boy's father
Sonny takes it upon himself to adopt the
kid
this is an attempt to impress his
girlfriend and save the relationship
when that doesn't work Sonny and Julian
are left with each other and bond in
ways neither of them expected I think
this movie has become more respected as
the years have gone by Big Daddy is
filled with some of Sandler's greatest
comedic moments no it's my Uncle Remus
what stopping to get a happy meal how
much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a
woodchuck could chuck wood yeah that's
what I thought shut up he has five your
plan what is it don't die man is you who
is good you know what else is good
smoking dope the surprisingly heartfelt
moments in this one are very important
to Sandler's career Sonny and Julian
have a relationship that's fun to watch
as we connect with them right away that
bond only gets stronger as the film goes
along
I know that's not it I know seeing John
Stewart in this movie is pretty surreal
considering where he ended up in his
hosting of The Daily Show he's also a
part of maybe the most heart-wrenching
scene in the movie I know this changes
everything I want you to be my dad Sonny
I know I don't tell but not sure that
can happen exactly the way we want as it
seems you already have a daddy
Big Daddy with Sandler at his funniest
while also incorporating some believable
drama in the mix it's absolutely one of
his best number three Michael Newman in
click this Academy Award nominated movie
is very polarizing even from the people
who like it when workaholic Michael
Newman is given a remote control that
can manipulate time he gleefully skips
through the boring parts of his life
however when the remote begins speeding
through larger and larger chunks of time
Michael finds himself frantically trying
to slow down with such a powerful device
taking control of him Michael struggles
to hold on to his wife and family a lot
of people don't like click and I get it
it's sort of a part of Sandler subpar
work but when I first saw this movie I
came out of the theater loving it the
last half-hour this movie is great upon
seeing it a few more times I realized
that it wasn't the whole movie I really
enjoyed it was just that last half hour
and how they wrapped up the story in
that last half-hour we see some of
Sandler's greatest work those few scenes
are so powerful it catapulted this
performance to number 3 no we just got
old that's like uh you're born and you
live and you die that's
I gotta go hey hang on Suzi push my next
meeting
I'm very ready it's fine are you are you
dizzy from the operation you're gonna
make me cry that ya don't have to go I
think the moment when Michael has the
remote take him to the last time he saw
his father is one of the strongest
scenes Sandler has ever done I love you
son
I love you to death
[Music]
I'll miss you
you know towards the end when we see
Michael laying in the street with his
family it caps off a performance that
really had an effect on me even people
who really hate click sometimes give
these emotional scenes that pass I had a
feeling you wanted to see me oh no not
you again but it hard
sure let's move on let's move on come on
number 2 Robbie Hart and the wedding
singer definitely the best drew
Barrymore Adam Sandler team up the
wedding singer has Sandler doing a lot
instead of cracking under the pressure
though he knocked it out of the park in
1995 Robbie Hart is a local nice guy he
wants to be a full time songwriter but
has become stuck in a rut as a wedding
singer realizing he isn't going anywhere
his fiancee doesn't show up to their
wedding and leaves Robbie soon after
devastated he's distracted by his
coworker and friend Julia to help plan
her wedding as the two become closer
it's obvious there's something more
between them than just friendship I
liked when Sandra plays the pure-hearted
guy as Robbie in the wedding singer he
pulls it off and then so he did all the
singing in this and as some of us
already knew he's pretty darn good
[Music]
give you my coat when you are cold need
you
let you hold the remote control we see
Robby go through a lot in this movie
including his fiancee not showing up to
their wedding his reaction to that works
pretty well basically indicated that
Linda was not coming today so it was a
bad note he has some great chemistry
with Barrymore here and their romance
develops at the perfect pace I want them
to be miserable because that's what I
know you're the best I know what people
eat prime rib and russain I mean as a
joke I can't do this anymore
Glenn and I set the date see how to play
our wedding while the wedding singer has
some great sentiment in it it also
contains plenty of hilarious moments
what are you doing I'm sorry I used to
be much stronger losing his mind and I'm
reaping all the benefits it also
survived one of the worst 80 ARS in the
history of film please pick me please
Julia please it is a genuinely sweet
little movie that is combined with some
of Sandler's usual comedic tinge it's
still a fun hour and a half if you
missed out on this one go watch it once
again things that could have been
brought to my attention yesterday Adam
Sandler has a few great performances
they could not fit into this top five so
before we get to number one here are a
couple honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Adam Sandler
performance is Charlie Fineman in rain
over me I remember seeing the trailer
for this and being surprised that Santa
was taking on something so serious when
I saw the movie I didn't love it but
Sandler shined as Fineman and he brought
his game up to a place that we didn't
even know he could reach Charlie Fineman
lost his wife and daughters in the
September 11th terrorist attacks years
later he's still mourning their deaths
and has isolated himself from connecting
with the rest of the world his old
college roommate Alan runs into him and
the two rekindled their friendship
Alan is also in a difficult position in
his life and when he realizes how unwell
Charlie really is he takes the difficult
steps to slowly try and get him the help
he needs
Sandler creates a performance that has
so many layers not a lot of big actors
can properly do justice to a character
like Charlie Charlie my father just died
yeah there's a store that's gonna open
up soon sells kitchen counters I want to
take you to they got Marla Tosh Charlie
my father just died yeah yeah I know I'm
gonna hang though he's such a closed-off
character that when we get a little bit
of information from him it's a big
moment you're waiting for most of the
film for him to open up and the payoff
comes in some marvelous scenes from
Sandler and I hear on the radio we get
there some man Duffy the plains robot
some mother guy this is to play the guy
Charlie used to be peeks through a few
times for some much-needed moments of
brevity in a very heavily dramatic film
Don Cheadle adds to these moments as his
characters unique relationship with
Charlie is front and center for most of
the movie Charlie's mother and
father-in-law are another driving force
behind wanting to get him help and
there's a scene where Charlie finally
opens up to them and that hits all the
right marks I get that you're in pain
but you got each other
you got each other and I'm the one who's
got to see how many girls all the time
everywhere I go it may not be a comedic
role but Sandlin was so good and reign
over me I could not put it at number one
I really hope we see him take some more
risks in the future we all know he's
capable of more fantastic performances I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your favorite Adam Sandler movie and/or
performance who do you want me to cover
next in the show
leave a comment and let me know make
sure to check out awesome comics that
went up on YouTube yesterday we're
covering the legacy of Dragon Ball Z we
have Malcolm on and Heather as well
follow me on twitter at awesome
underscore walter to take part in more
polls about who i may cover in the
future make sure you come back next week
when we take a look at the top 5 worst
Adam Sandler performances I'm sure
they're not that bad what you just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things I have ever heard I award you no
points and may God have mercy on your
soul
[Music]
[Applause]
in 1985 Robbie Hart is a local nice guy
who wants to be a full-time songwriter
oh shit
let's just freak me out I was trying to
hold it you feel like coming out like I
was like huh